le 20 octobre 2011 où moammar kadhafi et
tués par des miliciens libyen un espoir
de liberté de construction d'un bon
système politique comme l'annoncé les
démocraties qui ont précipité sa chute
dix ans après le déclenchement de
l'intervention est clair de la coalition
quel est le bilan sous alimentation
crise instabilité politique montée de
l'islamisme un état où pullulent
désormais les groupes armés auxquels
sont associés des tortures des
détentions arbitraires des attaques d
enlèvement d trafic de migrants
un bien triste anniversaire les premiers
morts civils tombent en février 2011
décrit par la presse comme des
populations inspiré par le printemps
arabe
au cours des semaines suivantes le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
vote de résolutions 1970 et 1973 elle
impose un embargo sur les armes et le
respect d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne
les états membres de la coalition vont
aller plus loin et décide de mettre en
action tous les moyens nécessaires pour
protéger selon eux les civils libyens
l'opération odyssey dawn sous la
houlette des etats-unis est donc mise en
place loin de s'en tenir à veiller sur
les populations
elle lance des frappes aériennes contre
les forces gouvernementales libyennes
l'otan assure le commandement militaire
de l'intervention à partir du mois
d'avril
la france va même jusqu'à douter les
rebelles en armes pour renverser le
pouvoir libyen et ce malgré l'embargo de
l'onu l'organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord refuse cessez le feu
que mouammar kadhafi propose rapidement
en lieu et place d'une solution pacifier
les rebelles se sont vus renforcée ont
donc contribué au basculement dans la
guerre civile
au cours de ces dernières années le pays
principalement déchiré entre deux camps
le gouvernement d'union nationale de
fayez al sa rage et l'armée nationale
libyenne dirigée par halifax tard alors
quels enseignements ont été tirés de
cette politique occidentale de la terre
brûlée
barack obama a lui même fini par
reconnaître qu'il s'était trompé
pire erreur probablement l'échec de la
préparation de la presse un coin ce qui
était la bonne chose à faire
dont l'intervention en libye en 2019
sergueï lavrov ministre des affaires
étrangères russe avait ainsi critiqué
l'opération de l'alliance
la guerre civile en libye qui s'est
longuement prolonger résulte de
l'intervention militaire illégitime de
l'otan ce qui a fait basculer le pays
dans le chaos
et on a fait une source d'instabilité
dans la région est un terrain fertile
pour le terrorisme
même emmanuel macron reconnu ce fiasco
en 2018 comptabilité qui a conduit quoi
qu'on pense d'un dirigeant d'imaginer
qu'on pouvait se substituer à la
souveraineté d'un peuple pour décider de
son futur nous avons collectivement
plongé la libye depuis ses années dans
l'anomie sans pouvoir régler la
situation
il faut dire que la france a largement
contribué à la réalisation de cette
opération sous l'impulsion de nicolas
sarkozy ce dernier avait motivé son
action aux prétendants mettre un terme
je cite à la folie meurtrière d'un
régime qui en assassinant son propre
peuple
les relations financières entre nicolas
sarkozy et moi marc kadhafi viennent
encore assombrir le regard porté à cette
guerre et chacun pourra faire son mea
culpa
alors que reste-t-il aux libyens leur
pays champ de bataille en proie à la
guerre civile est aussi ruiner jadis
prospère grâce à ses réserves de pétrole
il a vu tous les investisseurs fuir à
cause de l'instabilité politique une
crise économique sans précédent
accablent le pays mais il est notamment
par une inflation galopante
tout juste leur reste-t-il de la
perspective d'élections en fin d'année
un espoir après dix ans de chaos tandis
que les dirigeants occidentaux à
l'origine de cette catastrophe se sont
retirés de l'arène politique